what's going on guys welcome to the
second part of the ATX mini series
within our stocks and mathematics
calculations within Python always a
mouthful say it where we left off I was
showing you guys what ATX is now let's
actually bring ATX to life by
programming it ourselves before we get
started if you haven't been following
along linearly in this tutorial series
you are going to want to go ahead and
grab this sample data I did put it on my
website sent XCOM slash sample data note
the camel case if you don't camel case
it you won't get the data anyway just go
ahead and reach this page control a
control C and control V it into some
sample data dot text file that you put
in the same directory as this script so
with that let's go ahead and get go
ahead and get started here we're going
to go import numpy as NP if you have
been following along a lot of this stuff
is you mean identical the way we've done
it before
sample data League will open sample data
dot text with the intention to read and
then we'll go ahead and read it into
memory next split data equals sample
data dot split by new lon next we're
gonna say dates close P hi P low P open
P volume equals NP to load text what
text and although we want to load up
split data what delimiter do we want to
use we're going to use a delimiter and
actually let's go ahead and hit it Enter
key
calm down delimiter equals come
subsequently we do need to have unpack
equal to true so we can actually unpack
in a sign of these variables like so now
we're all done let's go ahead and get
into the ADX system so if you did follow
the previous tutorial because you will
had to follow the previous tutorial
actually this time the previous tutorial
was true range so we calculated true
range and then average true range and we
have to have done that because in this
video and ATX this system
uses average true range within it so you
will have to do the ATR actually so let
me go grab that code real quick and
bring it up the main thing that we're
going to want to grab from here is going
to be this TR function so define TR just
go ahead and highlight that come all the
way down to the return part hit copy and
just kind of pace that bad boy right in
there I'm gonna go ahead and delete
these print functions I'm already
confident in this worked so I don't need
that for debugging anymore and so that's
that so we leave the TR function right
in here now the next thing we want to do
is define directional movement because
that was really the first thing we need
to do is first do directional movement
get that positive directional movement
and at negative directional movement
identified and then we can define the
plus directional indebt indicator and
the negative directional indicator and
then we can do the true range on those
bad boys get the ADX plot that up and
just be overall awesome people so the
first thing we need to do is go into
find BM for directional movement it's
going to need the following variables in
here date open high/low close
yesterday's open yesterday's high
yesterday's low and yesterday's close
cool so that's DM and all the parameters
for the end that we need and welcome
back I just want to make some space so
first we have to calculate the
directional movement so that's gonna be
mu P okay I move up camel cased equals
high- yesterday's high and move down
equals yesterday's low minus the low of
today if 0 is less than the move up yet
move up is greater at the bantha move
down p BN equals move up else p.m.
equals 0
subsequently if 0 is less than move down
while move down is also simultaneously
greater and then move up ND m-
directional movement
equals whatever move down is otherwise
we want to do nd M equals zero so we'll
just save our progress here and let me
bring up that image one more time of the
definition of this so what we've just
done is this statement here in this
slide so as you can see we've got the
negative directional movement in the
positive rational movement defined and
if we bebop to the next slide so you get
the di the plus di and the minus di now
we got to do this 100 X 14 EMA PD M
divided by a TR and that's where a TR
comes in so let's go ahead and get that
underway so one more thing we do want to
add here of course is return D for date
PDM and then in the end make sure it's
in that order otherwise we're gonna have
some problem so we've done that now if
you recall we actually need that
exponential moving average so since I
report it's in that other script as well
or you can always grab exponential
moving average room right here syntax
calm rule a starting point dot pi it's
that full file that we graph stuff with
take this right here highlight
exponential moving average copy that
function paste that function right in
there come down a little bit now we're
going to define calc deep eyes so this
is going to be the calc
plus di and minus di and actually that
one's a pretty long one so I'm gonna go
ahead and cut the video here and
continue on in the next video so stay
tuned for the next video if you're
watching this one that next video is
already up so you don't have to wait or
anything for it anyway as always thanks
for watching